1 a.m. in a small town in central China
we're here to meet a woman and her baby
daughter on the run this is the only
hour she's willing to take the risk and
talk because Jiang Yan Yan is a mother
moving every day tonight this hotel room
is home she's not a criminal she's not a
dissident she's a Christian and she
happens to be the daughter of the local
priest in brown again he went to work as
usual it was a Saturday forcefully took
my father away
there was no paperwork at all they just
took him away we haven't seen him since
Adam we were gendered her who is this
government she shows us photos of the
government men who turned up at the
church November the 16th they took her
father and 23 of his parishioners away
they'd been trying to stop the
authorities from seizing land they
bought for a new church yeah UN Ren is
too frightened has returned there but on
a map she shows us where it is
we arrived at nan Lowe County church
early the following morning as a
daughter its rundown and appears
deserted to see how well this is it this
is the church that Jiang Xiao je and 23
we think of his parishioners have been
unable to worship Him since mid-november
within a few minutes quietly those who
aren't locked up begin to arrive my
mother was arrested here at the church
no arrest a warrant no everything's just
a it's really unsafe living here and
there's no freedom whenever we come to
service there are always restrictions on
the other side of town at the local
prosecutor's office a group of lawyers
has taken up the case they've been given
no access to any of those arrested
they're not even sure where they are the
key problem is the power of officials in
our country they behave like uncaged
monsters out to harm us all for them the
law doesn't exist moments later we
discover what he means a coach arrives
more christian supporters we assume but
they're not they're just the opposite
attacking the christians and the lawyers
why are they reacting that's why these
women reactivates don't they are paid
and backed by the local government they
come and go as required this is
organized behind the scenes by the
government for four hours the rentenmark
continue this determined intolerance of
religion incited by a corrupt local
government eventually those same
authorities is caught us out of the
building and out of the town yeah I miss
him very much
it's a month to the day since Jang young
young saw her father but do you think
he'll be home for Christmas I don't
think she and her daughter remain in
hiding
and frightened mark stone Sky News in
her nan province central China